شكرا لك ليال طبعا مشاهدينا نحن مازلنا
على العربيه مستمرون بهذه التغطيه
لانتخابات او النتائج الانتخابات التركيه
اذا حسمت هذه الانتخابات التركيه وابات
الاعلان رسميا عن احتفاظ الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بمنصبه لولايه جديده مساله وقت
وقبل قليل تعهد مرشح المعارضه
بمواصله العمل الديمقراطي من اجل الشعب
التركي معتبرا ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه
كانت الاقل في العداله منذ سنوات على حد
وصفه
[موسيقى]
وما زالت تتوارد ايضا التصريحات
حيث يقول بعد فوز اردوغان حزني عميق تجاه
الصعوبات التي تنتظر بلادنا اذا ما
زالتجار اوغلو يصاعد اتجاه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان على الرغم من انه النتيجه
النهائيه لم تعلن رسميا بعد وانما فوز
اردوغان يبدو اصبح محطما في اول تعليق له
حقيقه مشاهدينا بعد فوزه بهذه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه قال رجب طيب اردوغان انه
سيفعل ما يجعله يليق بثقه ناخبيه كما كان
على مدار العقدين الماضيين
اشكر كل الاعمال التي بذلها شعبنا وكلفنا
بحمل هذه المسؤوليه لاداره البلاد لمده
خمس سنوات مقبله اشكر شعبنا اذ اناط بنا
هذه المسؤوليه العظيمه ان شاء الله سنفعل
ما يجعلنا نليق بثقتكم وكما كنا جديرين
بثقتكم على مدار الواحد والعشرين عاما
الماضي ماذا قلت لكم قبلا هذا الحب لا
ينتهي ليس الى يوم الاحد بل الى القبر
والممات
ونحن الان سنذهب الى
مفرده العربيه في اسطنبول راويه قاسم يبدو
بانه ليست جاهزه راويه وانما مشاهدينا
نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
للاحتفالات احتفالات مناصري الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان الذي فاز اليوم بهذه
الانتخابات في الجوله الثانيه وهي تعد
الاولى في تاريخ تركيا الحديث حيث تجرى
جولد اعاده بسبب عدم تمكن احد المرشحين في
الانتخابات في الرابع عشر من ايار من
التفوق وان تكون التصويت له خمسين زائد
واحد الاناضول تقول الان بانه اردوغان
يتفوق في اثنتين وخمسين محافظه مقابل 29
بعد فرز 99% من الاصوات اذا هذه
الاحتفالات ما زالت مستمره في كافه
الولايات لمناصريه الرئيس التركيب هذه
الانتخابات اعتبرت بانها تاريخيه وبانها
كانت اكثر قساوه بين المعارضه وبين حزب
العداله والتنميه
ووصلت الى جوله ثانيه وهي المره الاولى
التي تصل فيها في تاريخ تركيا الحديث كان
التصعيد الكلامي بين المعارضه
والرئيسه رجب طيب اردوغان والتحالف الذي
ينتمي اليه في اوجه خلال الاشهر الماضيه
ملفات عديده كانت هي الاساسيه في حملاتهم
الانتخابيه ملف اللاجئين كان الورقه التي
كانت تضغط فيها
تجاهها او ضد الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
وتحالف الاحزاب طبعا منضويه والداعمه له
بالاضافه الى موضوع الاقتصاد والتضخم
والبطاله التي ايضا طالت تركيا
وايضا انهيار العمله التركيه كانت هذه
ابرز الملفات التي طغط على الحملات
الانتخابيه خلال الاشهر الماضيه حتى وصلنا
لهذه اللحظه وهو فوز الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان
ببلايه جديده الان اصبحت جاهزه معنا من
اسطنبول العربيه راويه قاسم راويه الاجواء
الاحتفاليه الاحتفاليه لديك
[موسيقى]
احتمالات مستمره هنا من امام مركز العداله
والتنميه
[موسيقى]
الداخليه
الذي تحدث الى المتواجدين هنا البلاد
[موسيقى]
الرئيس رجب طيب ارمان وايضا
يا سلام يمتلك هذا القاعده الشعبيه الاكبر
هنا في تركيا
ولا الانقلابات
[موسيقى]
هذا الرجل عن عرشه
الاحتفالات طبعا هذا اليوم الانتخابات
ناويه يعني عذرا الصوت الاحتفالات يطغى
على صوتك يعني لا نستطيع ان نسمعك بشكل
واضح ان نحاول ان نعود اليك ريثما تكون
الاجواء اهدا الى حد ما وانما مشاهدينا
نتابع على شاشه العربيه المقسومه قسمين
قسم الاحتفالات في انقره وايضا في اسطنبول
كان هناك احتفالات ايضا في اسطنبول بشكل
كبير طبعا الكل بانتظار الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان ان ينتقل الى انقره لالقاء خطاب
النصر في هذه الانتخابات التي كانت
قويه جدا بين المعارضه وبين الرئيس رجال
الطيب اردوغان والتحالف طبعا تحالف
الاحزاب معه
بالاضافه الى العديد من الملفات
الكلام
يعني في نهايه الامر كان السيد كليتش كان
ذكر ايضا قبل قليل في تصريحاته بانه هذه
الانتخابات هي
اقل عداله كانت موجوده ايضا في الاسابيع
الماضيه كانت المعارضه تتحدث عن الاعيب
قامت بها حزب التنميه والعداله العداله
والتنميه اتجاه هذه الانتخابات وكان دائما
التصعيد الكلامي هو سيد الموقف في الحملات
الانتخابيه كما ذكرنا سابقا ملفات عديده
كانت تستخدم من قبل الطرفين كاوراق ضغط
يجذبوا طبعا اصوات الناخبين البعض ايضا
يعتبر بانه يعني يطرح تساؤلات بانه تصويت
الخارج كان اكثر من خاصه في جوله الاعاده
كانت الكثافه في التصويت
[تصفيق]
ان تعذبهم من خلال ملفات كثيره من الممكن
كانت ان تهم الناخب التركي بالاضافه في
الطرف الاخر كانت تتحدث ايضا بعض الذين
يعني اقترعوا والذين شاركوا في هذه
الانتخابات بانه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
ايضا نجح في بعض الملفات ولكنه ايضا اخفق
بامور اخرى وخاصه اقتصاديه ساحاول ان اذهب
الى انقره الان مع مراسل العربيه زيدان
زنجلو
لنحاول ان نسمعه زيدان اهلا بك معنا
الاجواء لديك طبعا الكل بانتظار
خطاب الانتصار للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
ماذا لديك
لا ادري اذا كان صوتي سيصلكم بشكل صحيح
بسبب مكبرات او الصوت هنا
والاجواء واضح تمام نعم بانتظار الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان ما زال انصار الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان يتوافدون على المجمع الرئاسي
في العاصمه التركيه انقره طبعا الميدان
الرئيسي الذي من المنتظر ان يلقي به ان
يلقي منه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان خطاب
الشرطه او خطاب النصر امتلا بالكامل وهنا
الشارع الموازي لهذا الميدان يكاد تقريبا
ان يمتلئ بالكامل طبعا قبل قليل كان كمال
كلجدار اوغلو زعيم المعارضه التركيه قد
خرج بتصريح تحدث فيه عن ان المعركه ما
تزال مستمره وان
يعني بما معنى ان الدعاء الانتخابيه كانت
لصالح اردوغان كون ان اداره الدوله بيده
قبل قليل وفي هذه الاثناء او قبل لحظات
ميرال اكسينال بدات في طابع بدات كلمه لها
لم استطع متابعه كل ما جاءت به لكن ما
نقلته عنها وكاله الاناضول الرسميه بانها
هنات الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان على فوزه
ميرال اكشنريا ثاني اكبر
او ضيق زعيمه حزب الخير ثاني اكبر حزب
معارض في التحالف الطاوله السداسيه التي
رشح كماكي الجدار اوكلو
منافسه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ايضا دوله
بارتلي شريك الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في
تحالف الشعب وزعيم حزب الحركه القوميه
ايضا هنا اردوغان وقال على الجميع احترام
نتائج الانتخابات واحترام اراده الصندوق
ايضا سنان اوران المرشح الرئاسي الثالث في
الانتخابات او في الجوله الاولى ايضا ان
اردوغان وقال ان الاصوات التي كانت معه في
الجوله الاولى
ساهمت بشكل كبير في ترجيح كافه الميزان
على بحسب ما
قبل قليل ان احاول قدر الامكان تلخيص اخر
الاخبار التي وردتها بشكل سريع ايضا زيدان
زعيمه حزب الخير التركي ايضا قالت بانه
على اردوغان نتعلم دروس كبيره من نتائج
الانتخابات
وطبعا
نعود ونكرر مقاله بانه الانتخابات الاخيره
كانت اكثر انتخابات غير عادله منذ سنوات
اعود اليك زيدان
نعم بالضبط انا يعني تصريح مرار اكشن
بالكامل لا استطيع السماء وايضا من الشبكه
سيئه بسبب الضغط الكبير على شبكه الانترنت
لكن بالعموم ردود الافعال تتوالى حتى الان
يعني لا وجود افعال عنيفه من قبل المعارضه
او تصريحات كبيره من قبل المعارضه كما كان
متوقع بعد صدور النتائج الاوليه لكن حتى
الان الامور
تسير بشكل سلس حتى في تصريحات المعارضه
انصار الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان طبعا
اضافه الى هنا العاصمه انقره في اسطنبول
وفي عديد المدن التركيه يعتبرون في
الشوارع والكل كما قلت يعني انا لن اطيل
الوقوف امام الكاميرا ساحاول الابتعاد
واترك المشهد لزميلي المصور لوصف الاجواء
هنا كما قلت الرئيس اردوغان قبل ان يتوجه
الى انقره القى خطابا امام منزله في منطقه
اوسكودار في الجانب الاسيوي من اسطنبول
هنا
الشعب التركي بهذه التجربه الديمقراطيه
كما وصفها وايضا قال ان فوزه وفوز 85
مليون مواطن تركي ايضا انتقل بشده زعيم
المعارضه التركيه وطريقه اداره التحالف
وطريقه دخولها الانتخابات وخصوصا
الانتخابات البرلمانيه وكيفيه اعطاء مقاعد
لاحزاب صغيره وصفها وهنا كان يقصد احزاب
المستقبل والديمقراطيه والتقدم بقياده علي
بابا جان واحمد داوود اوغلو هذه الاحزاب
اخذت من مقاعد حزب الشعب الجمهوري في
البرلمان ولم توضف اي شيء لزعيم المعارضه
وفق ما قال الرئيس رجب طيب
زيدان بالنسبه لانقره واسطنبول هل الاصوات
الفارق كان كبير بين كلتش دار اوغلو وبين
الرئيس اردوغان
[موسيقى]
كان قليلا كما في الجوله الاولى يعني
تحديدا
يبدو ان العامل الاقتص في هذه الانتخابات
يبدو ان العامل الاقتصادي في هذه
الانتخابات في انقره والصمود كان له دور
اكثر من بقيه المناطق مثلا في مناطق
الزلزال عاد اردوغان وتقدما في الجوله
الثانيه بفارق كبير عنه كماجو اضافه الى
المناطق
الداعمه لارتك بطبيعه الحال هي في كل
الانتخابات مناطق وسط الاناضول ومناطق
البحر الاسود هذه ايضا اعطت اصواتها بكثره
لاردوغان يعني العمل الايديولوجي كان
حاسما في تلك المناطق لكن على ما يبدو ان
العامل الاقتصادي كان له دور في
المدن الكبرى اسطنبول وانقره وفي هذه
الانتخابات يعني نتحدث يمكن للمره الاولى
الرئيس التركي لا يكسب اسطنبول لكن يفوز
في هذه الانتخابات يعني مقوله ان من يربح
اسطنبول يكسب في الانتخابات التركيه هذه
المره
اردوغان خالف القاعده تقدم كمان
اردوغان لكن اردوغان في اسطنبول طبعا تقدم
لكن اردوغ في المجمل هو من فاز بهذه
الانتخابات
لا يخسر في بعض الولايات اردوغان هل تؤثر
زيدان ام المهم كانت النتيجه النهائيه
[موسيقى]
طبعا النتيجه النهائيه لكن لها مؤشرات بان
التضخم والعامل الاقتصادي كان له عام او
كان عاملا اساسيا في خيارات النافذين في
هذه المدن الكبرى وانا بعد الجوله الاولى
يعني عندما خسر اردوغان في انقره واسطنبول
كنت اقول ان العامل الاقتصادي كان حاسما
في هذه المدن اكثر من العامل الايديولوجي
يتحدث عن هذه المدن اكثر المدن التي تاثرت
بالتضخم وغلاء المعيشه وبالتالي انعكس هذا
الموضوع على صندوق الاقتران لا شك ان هل
تؤشر ايضا للانتخابات البلديه في 20 24
زيدان هل هي مؤشر ايضا هذه النتيجه
[موسيقى]
لا يمكن الحكم الان عن انتخابات
2024 لكن هو اعلن ان اردوغان في خطابه قبل
قليل في اسطنبول ان الهدف القادم هو
استعاده اسطنبول من المعارضه لكن هذا
الموضوع يتطلب جهود مضاعفه لتحسين الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه
تجاوز موضوع التضخم على وجه التحديد لا
سيما في المدن الرئيسيه في اسطنبول وفي
انقره او حتى ايضا في بعض المدن الكبرى
لكن اسطنبول على وجه التحديد على الرئيس
التركي في المرحله القادمه ان يكون يكون
جهود اكبر في اسطنبول سواء في موضوع
تحديدا في الموضوع العامل الاقتصادي وهو
اكثر ما يهم سكان اسطنبول والمدن الكبرى
كما ذكرت يعني هذه المدن تاثر اكثر من
غيرها في موضوع غلاء المعيشه والتضخم لكن
بالمحصله يعني النتيجه النهائيه هي التي
اوصلت اردوغان الى
الان يكون الرئيس الثالث عشر في تركيا لكن
طبعا كما قلت قبل قليل ان موضوع خساره
اسطنبول يعني او من يفوز باسطنبول يفوز
لتركيا هذه القاعده اليوم تجاوزها اردوغان
في هذه الانتخابات لكن هي مؤشر على ان
العامل الاقتصادي او الاقتصاد بحاجه الى
مراجعه من قبل اداره الرئيس التركي
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه ايضا لهذا اليوم الانتخابي اذا
اردنا تقييمه من الناحيه من الناحيه
الاجراءات الامنيه من ناحيه مره بسلاسه هل
كان هناك مشاكل خاصه بين مناصري المعارضه
ومناصري رجب طيب اردوغان ام مره بثلاثه
زيدان هل سجلت اي احداث
بعموم الولايات لم تسجل احداث يمكن ان
يتطرق اليها بانها عكرت
الانتخابات لكن طبعا كان في كما يعني في
كل
الانتخابات الماضيه وفي الجوله الاولى كان
هناك بعض المشاهدات او بعض المشاحنات لكن
رؤساء اللجان الانتخابيه قاموا بالتعاطي
مع هذا الموضوع ايضا الشرطه كانت منتشره
حوالي 700 الف عنصر امني كان منتشر في
مراكز الانتخابات لحمايه عمليه الاقتراع
بالتالي نستطيع ان نتحدث عن ان العمليه
صارت بسلاسه خصوصا ان الانتخابات
والاجراءات كانت سريعه لان الانتخابات
كانت فقط انتخابات رئاسيه كما لاحظنا ان
عمليه التصويت كانت تسيير
اللي كانت تسير بثلاثه وسرعه وايضا حتى
عمليه فرز الاصوات صارت بنحو سريع جدا كما
وهذا الموضوع كان متوقع الصباح وقال هذا
موضوع قاله رئيس الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
لان النتائج ستصدر في سرعه لان الانتخابات
فقط هي انتخابات رئاسيه وليس هناك
انتخابات برلمانيه وبالتالي الكورس عمليات
الفرس لن تستغرق وقت اطول بالتالي نستطيع
ان نقول الى ان العمليه الانتخابيه صارت
بسلاسه بشكل جيد يبقى ما اكده حتى رئيس
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات بعد اقفال
صناديق الاقتراع مباشره في اول تصريح صحفي
قال ان العمليه صارت دون مشاكل وصارت
بطريقه طبيعيه او بشكل سلس كما قال ترنب
المشهد التركي منذ سنوات بعد هذه النتيجه
اليوم بعد القاء خطاب النصر ما هي الخطوات
اللاحقه بالنسبه
لحزب العداله والتنميه وبالنسبه طيب
اردوغان بالنسبه للحكومه
[موسيقى]
نقطه مهمه موضوع الاغلبيه البرلمانيه التي
حازها الرئيس اردوغان في الجوله الاولى في
انتخابات في الرابع عشر من مايو ستكون
يعني عاملا المساعدا
في الخطوات التاليه للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان دون ان يكون هناك تصويت من احزاب
المعارضه لكن بطبيعه الحال ربما ربما
ونتحدثون على الطرف الاخر في المعارضه
ربما نشهد بعض التغيرات في الوجوه لاسيما
ان هذه الهزيمه التي تلقتها المعارضه
واتحدث هنا عن حزب الشعب الجمهوري قد بدات
ملامح الانتقادات طفال زعيم المعارضه
كمالك منذ نهايه الجوله الاولى واذكر
عندما كنا في تابلت الجوله الاولى في
الخامس عشر من مايو بعد يوم واحد فقط من
صدور النتائج الاوليه وقبل معنا
الانتخابات الرئاسيه ذهبت الى جوله اعاده
خساره البرلمان كان لها وقع كبير على
انصار وقيادات حتى في حزب الشعب الجمهوري
كان هناك انتقادات لاداء في الجدار اوغلو
وكيفيه جمع اطراف غير
دائما
لالقاء خطاب النصر اشكرك حتى الان على كل
هذه التفاصيل وعلى ايضا النقل الصوره لنا
عن هذه الاحتفالات
لمناصري الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان شكرا لك
حتى اللحظه
نذكر مشاهدينا طبعا بموقف مرشح المعارضه
التركيه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه كمالك
والذي قال ان منفسه استفاد من امكانات
الدوله كافه
في خطاب له ان الانتخابات كانت اكثر
انتخابات غير عادله في السنوات الاخيره
كما شدد مرشح المعارضه على انه سيواصل
الكفاح داعيا مناصريه الى مواصله النضال
من اجل الديمقراطيه كليتش اعرب عن حزنه
العميق تجاه الصعوبات التي تنتظر تركيا
على حد قوله
والان سنتحدث عن ما حدث في مدينه سيفاس
وهي احدى المعاقل الهامه المؤيده للرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان والتي ربما يلخص ما حدث
في عموم البلاد بحسب تقرير لواشنطنبو ماذا
قالت الصحيفه قالت ان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اعتمد في تفوقه في هذه المنطقه في
انتخابات الرابع عشر من مايو على من
وصفتهم الصحيفه
بالمتدينين القوميين او بمزيج من الاثنين
بسهوله تامه فاز اردوغان في المدينه
بالجوله الاولى من الانتخابات بحصوله على
69% من الاصوات في سيفا تحالف اردوغان
البرلماني حقق نجاحا جيدا في هذه المنطقه
الا ان حزب العداله والتنميه والذي ينتمي
اليه الرئيس خسر عشرات الاف من الاصوات
منذ الانتخابات الاخيره عام 2018 لكن رغم
هذا الكبير مشاهدينا عن مرشح المعارضه في
الجوله الاولى اعتبر البعض ان محدوديه
الخيارات او القلق من المعارضه دفع باتجاه
التصويت لايردوغانم واشنطن بوست بمواطنين
صوتوا
واستطلعت ارائهم واعتبرت احداهن انه في
حال وجود مرشح افضل في المعارضه لكانت
صوتت له بينما انتقد اخر تعهد كليتش دار
اوغلو باطلاق سراح سجناء سياسيين بمن فيهم
صلاح الدين دميتاج الزعيم السابق لحزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي عضو بحزب الشعب
الجمهوري المعارض في سباس قال لواشنطن
بوست انه بينما ركز الحزب على الجانب
الاقتصادي
ركز تحالف اردوغان على الخطاب القومي
باتهام كليتش دار اوغلو بالتحالف مع
جماعات ارهابيه وبشكل عام حاول اردوغان في
الفتره السابقه للانتخابات تقديم حوافز
للمواطنين منها مثلا زياده اجور العاملين
في القطاع العام زياده
الضريبيه اما الاقتصاد فكان عامل حاسم
لسكان وناخبي سباس التي تصل نسبه البطاله
فيها الى 5% من المواطنين لكن يبدو ان
تاثير الاغراءات الرئاسيه لم يظهر سريعا
مع نسبه البطاله التي اجبرت مئات الالاف
من السكان على مغادره تيباس والاستقرار
بمدن اخرى في تركيا بما في ذلك اسطنبول
طبعا لمتابعه هذا المشهد سنذهب الى ضيفنا
دكتور سمير صالحه استاذ العلوم السياسيه
من اسطنبول اهلا بك دكتور سمير هذه
الانتخابات انتهت النتائج ايضا لم تصدر
رسميا ولكن اصبحت واضحه بان الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان هو رئيس لتركيا لمده خمس
سنوات قادمه الان كنا نتحدث عن سباس هل
مثلا هذه المنطقه يمكن ان تكون تجسيدا لما
حقيقه حصل في كل الولايات التركيه وعلى
اساسه قامت بالانتخاب
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا يعني مساله
سواس برايي مهمه للغايه لانها تكون جزء من
النقاشات التي ستبدا الليله او اعتبارا من
صباح الغد في صفوف المعارضه تحديدا
ارتدادات
الهزيمه وكيف ستتفاعل على الارض كيف
ستتعامل المعارضه باتجاه مراجعه سياساتها
وموضوع اين اخطانا ولماذا هزمنا في معركه
الانتخابات الجوله الثانيه الانتخابات
برايك عند المعارضه وهي كانت سببا لهذه
النتيجه التي وصلت اليها اليوم
صحيح هذا عمل اساسي مهم لانه كما تتذكرين
عندما كان في نقاشات داخل صفوف الطاوله
السداسيه
وتصلب كمال بان يكون هو المرشح المعارضه
حزب الخير او الجيد غادرت الطاوله ثم بعد
ضغوطات شعبيه حزبيه كثيره عادت اليها كان
في ردات فعل انه كمان من الصعب ان يعني
يجلس في مقعد منافسه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان التركيز كان على اسمين رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول ورئيس بلديه انقره وقتها الملفت
الان انه قبل قليل
قيادي بارز في حزب ميرال اكشنار تحدث وقال
انه الهزيمه يتحمل مسؤوليتها
كمارو الذي اصر على ان يكون هو هل
المعارضه ستحاسب
دكتور سمير يعني الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
بنفسه قال بانه سترون بانه المعارضه
ستحاسب كليتش دار اوغلو هل ستقوم بذلك
يعني طبعا سيكون نقاش واسع جدا داخل
التكدر المعارضه كتكتل نقطه اولى واحتمال
ان تبدا عمليه الشرزمه في صفوف هذا
التحالف لكن سيكون ايضا هناك عمليه نقد
ذاتي داخل الاحزاب نفسها يعني على مستوى
التكتل واحد وعلى مستوى الاحزاب التي
التحقت بهذا التكتب بالطاوله
السداسيه واظن انه عمليه النقد الذاتي
لابد ان تبدا مع
حزب الخاسر الاول والاكبر حزب الشعب
الجمهوري لكن كمال تبعتي انت ايضا في
رسائله قبل قليل
يتمسك بانه سيبقى في الواجهه وانه سيواصل
عمليه
المواجهه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان السؤال
هو لديه هذه النيه ومصر على النضال كما
ذكر هو نفسه ولكن السؤال هل سيسمح له هل
حزب سيحاسبه ويقول له يجب ان تتنحى ويكون
هناك اسماء جديده وخاصه اسماء شابه يقوم
بالعمل عليها لتسويقها في الانتخابات
اللاحقه ولتكوين ايضا
جو تغيير حقيقي
يحضن هذه المعارضه
تماما تماما اتفق معك يعني اذا لم يكن
الان هناك عمليه نقد ذاتي في حزب الشعب
الجمهوري ولماذا وصلت الامور الى هذه
النتيجه ومن الذي سيتحمل المسؤوليه اذا
يبقى الحزب في مكانه
سيعاني من ازمه اكبر ما هي هذه الازمه
الاكبر حزب الشعب الجمهوري يعني اليسار
التقليدي في تركيا قيادات اليسار التقليدي
التي مثلت دائما المعارضه التركيه
من هذا النوع في اي انتخابات كانت تتشارزم
وتنفصل ويكون هناك عمليات انشقاقات حزبيه
خروج من الحزب على مستوى القيادات وبعد
ذلك بدانا نرى احزاب جديده معارضه صغيره
جديده هل كمان
جاهز في ساعات المقبله لتحمل ارتدادات
سيناريو من هذا النوع انا اظن انه الاصوات
ستت في صفوف قيادات حزب الشعب الجمهوري
تطالب بمؤتمر استثنائي عاجل انتخابات
مبكره لرئيس جديد اذا ما يعني حدث العكس
وتمسك حزب الشعب الجمهوري بكمال كريش فهذا
يعني انه المساله ستنعكس سلبا اكثر فاكثر
على هذا الحزب هل من اسماء في حزب الشعب
الجمهوري مرجحه لان تاخذ مكان كمالك بحال
هو تنحى او بحال قبل بان يكون هناك
وجوه جديده تتصدر المشهد من اجل اعطاء
نظره جديده تجاه هذه المعارضه والعمل
عليها للسنوات المقبله
يعني اظن انه الحظوظ الاكبر هي
لصالح رئيس بلديه اسطنبول ورئيس بلديه
انقره لدين وقفاه الى جانب كمال في الجوله
الثانيه وشاركها بشكل فعال مباشر في
الحملات الانتخابيه
والدعائيه كلا الرجلين الان براييه يعني
يحاولان ان اتجاه التاثير داخل الحزب لفتح
الطريق امام التغيير على مستوى
القياده لكن كما تعرفين انت ايضا الانماء
في موقع رئيس بلديه الاول في اسطنبول
وصحيح في انقره هل يسمح الحزب لهما
بالتخلي عن هذه المنصبين
باتجاه التنافس على من سيقود حزب الشعب
الجمهوري بعد كمال وهذه ايضا مساله معقده
على مستوى
سمير البعض يعتبر بانه الان
اردوغان لديه خمس سنوات ولن يخشى اي شيء
يخسره بعد هذه الخمس سنوات لانه لا يحق له
يعني هناك ايضا جدل اذا كان يحق له بعد
خمس سنوات ان يترشح ام لا ولكن البعض
يعتبر بانه الان ليس لديه اي شيء يخسره
لانه ليس لديه انتخابات لن يترشح بعد خمس
سنوات فلذلك
سيقوم بكل ما يريد ان يفعله ومنها مثلا
سيسعى الى عزل اكرم امام اوغلو عن البلديه
هل هذا هل هذا سيحصل دكتور قبل ان تجيبني
سنه سنذهب الى الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
دكتور سعدون ربما الان يتحدث رئيس العليا
للانتخابات احمد ينير نتابعه
[تصفيق]
الساده الاعلاميين
الاعزاء صناديق الانتخابات داخل تركيا
اكثر من 99 في الابيات تم
فتحها
اما
صناديق
خارج
الى النسبه وصلت الى 88
في المئه سيد رجب طيب باردو ان حصل الى
حاله
وتسعه وخمسين
في من الخارج
وسيدار اولو 40 اما المعدل للخارج والداخل
الى الان نسبه تسعه
وتسعين فاصله 43 في المئه سيد رجب الطيب
حصل على اثنين وخمسين فاصل في المئه اما
السيد
حصل على
47,80 في الاب مئه
من اعتبارا من
مليونين و250 الف صوت هو الفرق بين كلا
مرشحين ونسبه
صفر فاصله واحد في الايه فقط هذه النسبه
لن تغير النسبه الموجوده
وبالتالي ونتيجه لهذه الانتخابات
السيد رجب طيب اردوغان اختير كرئيسا
للجمهوريه التركيه خلال هذه الفتره
ومرحله في
الانتخابات
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات نحن كنا حياديين
اشكر جميع المشاركين وجميع ممثلي الاحزاب
السياسيه في جميع
مراكز في جميع المحافظات والولايات والمدن
جميع المشاركين في
مراكز اشكر جميع من قدموا الدعم النا في
من اجل نجاح هذه الانتخابات منذ الاعلان
الاول
لتاريخي هذه
الانتخابات وحتى هذه اللحظه انتم
اعلميات اشكركم فردا فردا
وابارك نتائج هذه الانتخابات الشعب التركي
والجمهوريه التركيه
ايضا مشاهدينا رجب طيب اردوغان رئيسا
لتركيا رسميا بعد ان اعلنت هذا الخبر وهذه
النتائج الهيئه العليا للانتخابات في
تركيا
فاصبح الان رجب طيب اردوغان رسميا هو رئيس
لتركيا لخمس سنوات مقبله قبل ان اعود الى
وطبعا الهيئه العليا شكرت الاتراك على هذه
الانتخابات
وعلى ايضا مشاركتهم في هذه الانتخابات على
كل حال قبل ان اعود الى ضيفنا دكتور سمير
صالحه ساذهب الان الى برلين
راغده اهلا بك معنا اكبر جاليه تركيا
متواجده في المانيا كيف كان تصويتها وكيف
هو رضاها عن هذه النتيجه في الانتخابات
اهلا بك يا ميسون يعني سمعنا قبل قليل
نتائج هذه الانتخابات اعتقد التصويت
بالخارج جاء بنسبه 64% للرئيس يعني الذي
فاز الان بولايه جليد جديده رجب طيب
اردوغان وهذا في الواقع يعكس ميسون يعني
اتجاهات التصويت الى ما اردنا القول
للجاليه التركيه الاكبر في الخارج في
الواقع وهي موجوده في المانيا هناك قرابه
الثلاث ملايين تركيا يعيشون هنا في
المانيا اكثر بقليل من 700 الف منهم يحق
لهم التصويت شاركوا في هذه الانتخابات
ويعني اصلا في الجوله الاولى التي جرت قبل
اسبوعين ايضا ذهبت اكثر من 60% من اصوات
الناخبين الذين شاركوا هنا للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان لذلك الاتراك هنا يعني قياسا على
السنوات الماضيه ايضا بشكل عام تذهب
اصواتهم لاردوغان لاسباب كثيره ربما يعني
اهمها بانه الكثير منهم لا يشعرون بانهم
المانيا احتوتهم كمواطنين عدد كبير منهم
او معظمهم يعني خاصه من الذين جاؤوا في
الخمسينات والستينات يعني كعمال مهاجرين
ما زالوا يعني لا يحملون الجنسيه
الالمانيه ليس هناك طريق امامهم لان
يكونوا مواطنين المان كاملين حقوق لا
يمكنهم المشاركه في الانتخابات هنا لذلك
يرون بانه البديل على ذلك هو ان يستمروا
بالمشاركه في الانتخابات في تركيا رغم
انهم لا يعيشون هناك لا يعانون يعني من
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه سمعت بانه زميلنا في
تركيا كان يتحدث انه الازمه الاقتصاديه او
الوضع الاقتصادي كان في طليعه اهتمامات
الناخبين هنا الاهتمامات مختلفه كليا
ميسون لانه الاتراك الذين يعيشون هنا
يعيشون في المانيا يذهبون الى تركيا ربما
زياره مره او مرتين في العام ويعني لا
يشعرون بهذه الوطاه الاقتصاديه التي يشعر
بها المواطنون الاتراك هنا يعني ربما هذا
يفسر بعض اتجاهات اصوات الناخبين الاتراك
الموجودين هنا في المانيا وبالطبع يعني
الليله ستكون هناك احتفالات على الارجح
لهؤلاء الذين صوتوا
لاردوغان واعلن فوزه قبل قبل لحظات من
الان يعني من المبكره ايضا ان يكون هناك
تصريحات
للتصريحات رسميه لالمانيا تجاه هذا
الانتخاب وهذه النتيجه لانه من المعلوم
بان الدول يعني لا تقدم التهاني قبل ان
تكون النتيجه النهائيه ورسميه ولكن
الراي العام راغده وخاصه بالنسبه لعلاقات
تركيا والمانيا ماذا يمكن ان نتحدث عنها
بعد فوز
اردوغان بولايه جديده في تركيا
نعم الان وقد صدر يعني الاعلان الرسمي
ربما تصدر الليله يعني رساله تهنئه من
الخارجيه او حتى من مقر المستشاريه
الالمانيه ولكن بالفعل ميسون علاقه تركيا
او علاقه المانيا بتركيا او بالرئيس
التركي تحديدا بتركيا تحت ولايه اردوغان
لم تكن علاقه سهله كانت علاقه صعبه جدا
على مدار السنوات الماضيه نعلم بانه
اردوغان استخدم ورقه اللاجئين السوريين
اكثر من مره الابتزاز المانيا تحديدا
ويعني هو دائما يقول بانه نحن ندافع او
نحن نوقف هؤلاء اللاجئين من ان ياتوا الى
اوروبا وهناك شعور هنا يعني لدى السياسيين
الالمان بانه المانيا تدفع يعني تدفع
ماليا ثمنا باهضا يعني محاوله ابقاء
اللاجئين او محاوله ما يقولنا بعض
السياسيين يصفوا بالابتزاز من ناحيه
الرئيس التركي لازمه اللاجئين تحديدا ولكن
ابعد من ذلك يعني الرئيس
يوصف في الاوساط السياسيه الالمانيه بانه
رئيس لا يمكن التنبؤ يعني بتصرفاته ربما
او لا يمكن التنبؤ بردود افعاله ولذلك
يعني الان هذه العلاقه الصعبه ستستمر لانه
رغم انها صعبه ولكن بالنسبه لالمانيا
بالطبع هي علاقه مهمه جدا يعني بالعلاقه
مع العلاقه التركيه الارمنيه رئيسيه في
طليعه اهتمامات الخارجيه العلميه بطبيعه
الحال بسبب هذه الجاليه الكبيره التركيه
الموجوده هنا وايضا لانه المانيا ترى في
تركيا شريك رغم انه شريك صعب ربما ترى
فيها شريك يعني على مستويات عديده ليس
ناحيه مساله اللاجئين وما الى ذلك ولكن من
الناحيه السياسيه من الناحيه الدفاعيه
يعني تركيا هي عضو في النيتو والان يعني
تعلمين بانه المانيا يزداد دورها ايضا
يعني بشكل كبير في الاشهر الماضيه داخل
حلف الناتو لذلك سياسيا دفاعيا ومن نواحي
كثيره جدا اجتماعيه هي علاقه مهمه جدا
بالنسبه لالمانيا ولكنها صعبه وهذه
العلاقه الصعبه والتي لا يمكن التنبؤ بها
ربما ستستمر مع يعني اعاده مع فوز اردوغان
في هذه كل هذه المعلومات رغده بهنا مراسله
العربيه كنت معنا من برلين
مشاهدينا فوز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وراءه شبكه عمرها عقدا بحسب
فاينانشيل تايمز البريطانيه الصحيفه قالت
ان نفوذ الدوله وسخائها يفسران شعبيه
الرئيس التركي لدى الناخبين وارتباط
الكثير منهم بحزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم
فانشون تايمز اضافت ان الدعم الحكومي يضع
الملايين في موقف يخافون معه من رئاسه دون
اردوغان على سدتها نقلت الصحيفه عن خبراء
قولهم ان عدد فئات تعتمد على بقاء حزب
العداله والتنميه في السلطه لمواصله تلقي
الفوائد من الدوله ووفق تايمز دائما تمتد
الشبكات القويه التي اقامها حزب العداله
والتنميه الى الاعمال التجاريه وذلك
بتقديم العطاءات والفرص للمجموعات القريبه
من الحزب ورجاله كما ان الحزب قام بتوظيف
العديد من اقارب اعضائه في مناصب رفيعه في
الادارات في المنظمات غير الحكوميه ايضا
في الجامعات والبلديات ورغم ذلك وصف عضو
في العداله والتنميه ما ذكر بانه دعايه من
المعارضه واعتبر ان الحزبه تمكن عبر سنوات
من كسب معاقل انتخابيه تاريخيه لاحزاب
كبيره ايضا كما اكد هذا العضو ان الحزب
استخدم شبكته الكبيره للبقاء على اتصال
دائم مع المؤيدين والذين قد يدعمون الحزب
في مرحله ما في تايمز ختم تقريرها بالقول
ان الفوائد الفعليه لدعم حزب العداله
والتنميه لا تقتصر على الوظائف الحكوميه
بل تصل للمساعدات الاجتماعيه لكبار السن
والفقراء والاغاثه في حالات الكوارث دائما
نحن مستمرون مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
لنتائج الانتخابات وخاصه بعد اعلان الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان رسميا رئيسا لتركيا لمده
خمس سنوات ينضم الي الان من اسطنبول معنى
دكتور مهند حافظ اوبلو الاكاديمي والباحث
السياسي دكتور مهند اهلا بكم معنا
اردوغان رئيس لتركيا لمده خمس سنوات جديده
هذه النتيجه كانت متوقعه بعد الجوله
الاولى ولكن حسب الاصوات التي تابعناها
البعض يعتبر بانه اصوات سنان اوغان لم
تعطي هذه النتيجه التي صورت بانها كما
يقال عنها بيضه القبان
استاذه ميسون وجميع المشاهدين بالفعل يعني
الرئيس اردوغان لم يفوز باصوات سنان اوغان
وهو كان واضحا منذ البدايه قال اننا لم
نقم باي مساومه مع سنان اوغان فقط سنان
اوغان طبعا كان يطمح سنان اوغان الى
اللقاء الرئيس اردوغان وان يكون له
حظوة كونه يعني ربما لديه بعد نظر يختلف
عن اوميت اوزداغ ويختلف عن كثير من الشاشه
الاتراك في المعارضه ادرك تماما بان رئيس
اردوغان عمليا هو من سوف يكون الرئيس هذا
من جهه من جهه ثانيه اراد ان يرسل رساله
للمواطن التركي بانني لست مهتما بالمصالح
الشخصيه بقدر ما اني مهتم بمصلحه الوطن
قدم مصلحه الدوله التركيه وشعب التركي على
مصلحته الشخصيه وهنا ايضا ابانا صوره سيئه
للمعارضه ولاوميت اوزداغ الذي عقد صفقات
مع المرشح كمالك
لتولي بعض الحقائب الوزاريه ولبعض المنافع
الشخصيه كانت يعني كانت ضاربه
المدى وليست مرجحه للرئيس اردوغان بطبيعه
الحال ولكن المعارضه ايضا دكتور تسوق بانه
هناك لعيب كانت خلال فتره هذه الحملات
الانتخابيه
هل حجه الاعيب من قبل المعارضه وقالت بانه
بعد هذا الانتخابات سنتحدث عن كل شيء ماذا
نتوقع ان تكون هذه الالاعيب ما هي طبيعتها
باي مجالات مثلا
يعني مع الاسف المعارضه كما قال الرئيس
اردوغان يعني الرجل يعلم تماما دولته
ويعلم شعبه ويعلم الاحزاب السياسيه قال
منذ يومين كلام في غايه الخطوره وغايه
الاهميه وهو ان مشكله الديمقراطيه في
تركيا انها ليست فيها معارضه صحيحه
وحقيقيه هذا كلام في غايه الوضوح وغايه
الصراحه يعني اليوم منذ 12 استحقاقا
انتخابيا او تنافس انتخابي تنافس به كمال
كريشتار اوغلو مع اردوغان ويخسر في الاثنا
عشر تنافسا وكل مره هناك تلاعب وهناك ولكن
دكتور يعني كما قال الزعيم حزب الخير انه
يجب على اردوغان هذه المره ان يتعلم درسا
من هذه الانتخابات يعني ايضا الارقام التي
حصلت عليها المعارضه ليست بالسهله لم يكن
نجاحا سهلا بالنسبه للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان هل سنتوقع منه اي تغيير لم تكن
سهله ابدا يعني حتى وصلنا الى الجوله
الاعاده وهي اول مره بتاريخ تركيا الحديث
[موسيقى]
يتغير
يعني لم يتغير حقيقه منذ اكثر من 20 سنه
والناخب التركي لم يغير من مزاجه ويواصل
في انتخاب الرئيس اردوغان مهما اختلف
الوضع بالنسبه للمعارضه ومهما اختلف
المرشح يعني اكثر من
مرشحين فاصل تسعه بالمئه هي رقم كبير
كبير بالفعل ولكنه لم يكفي لازاحته
لازاحته وانهاء حكم اردوغان الذي امتد الى
اكثر من عقدين يعني نعم المعارضه تحقق نسب
مرتفعه بالمقارنه مع الانتخابات
الماضيه ولكن ما الفائده يعني كل هذه
الاصوات الان لم يعني تجعل المعارضه تفوز
يعني بنهايه المطاف حتى لو كان واحد
بالمئه
الفائز هو من يحقق هذه النسبه
مثل ما قلت لك يعني بالمقارنه مع
الانتخابات الماضيه ربما المعارضه حققت
نتيجه عاليه ولكنها يعني
هذا الانتصار ضيق
ويحتاج اردوغان الان لتقديم شيء للناس
وبشكل سريع جدا خاصه بانه الان اليوم ذكر
بانه هو يقدر ثقه الناخبين وبانه بما معنا
ها انه سيكون عند حسن ظنهم دائما ماذا يجب
على اردوغان ان يقدم للاتراك بشكل سريع
كهديه لما اعطيه اياه اليوم
لا اظن بان اردوغان يحاول ارضاء الجزء
الاخر الذي لم يصوت له يعني النسب التي
فاز بها
بالدوله دورتين التي مضت يعني كانت ليست
مختلفه عن هذه النسبه ولكن اردها فقط يسعى
ماذا سيقدم للناس لانصارهم الذين اعطوه
هذه الاصوات والذين وقفوا الى جانبه
ودعموه حتى اخر لحظه
في الحال الان يعني
يستفيدون من بعض الامكانيات التي تتيحها
الدوله ولكن اذا ما تحدثنا عن شيء خاص لا
يوجد شيء حقيقه اغلب الناس يعني الذين
يناطرونه ويدافعون عنه
تماما انهم من الطبقه الفقيره يعني ليس
لهم الكثير من المطالب وليس لديهم الكثير
من ما يحصلونه عليه ثقه تماما ان المعارضه
بتركيا وشيء غريب ربما يعني تاتي من الفئه
الغنيه والثريه والاصحاب الوظائف بانه
الرئيس اردوغان بنفسه قال باننا سنستعيد
اسطنبول اذا لم يستطع استعاده اسطنبول
وتحسين مثلا الاقتصاد لانه اصبح معلوما
بانه انقره اسطنبول لم يعطوه الاصوات بسبب
هذا التضخم وبسبب الوضع الاقتصادي
لما تقولينه الصح يعني فعلا وضع بالمدن
الكبيره مثل اسطنبول وانقره يعني مختلف
تماما عن المدن الصغرى والقرى يعني هي لم
تصوت للرئيس اردوغان لان يعني التضخم نشعر
بالتضخم هنا في اسطنبول نشعر بغلاء السلع
في اسطنبول اكثر من اي مكان
بطبيعه الحال الناخب لم يصوت لصالح
اردوغان كان يرغب بالتغيير ولكن
بنهايه المطاف الانتخابات لا تجرى فقط على
اسطنبول وانقره يعني اصوات حتى اقصى يعني
منطقه في تركيا تحسب مثل اصوات اسطنبول
فيعني لم تكفي يعني اصوات اسطنبول وانقره
وازمير وانطاليا والمدن الكبرى لتغيير
الرئيس اردوغان في هذه الجوله ايضا دعني
اذهب الى دكتور مهند مجددا دكتور مهند
على الرغم من انه انتقادات كبيره للمعارضه
ولكن ايضا هناك انتقادات لحزب العداله
والتنميه
وخاصه بانه الرئيس اردوغان هذه الولايه
الثالثه
من الممكن لا يكون يحق له ان يترشح مره
اخرى هل العداله والتنميه ستعمل على تجهيز
وجه جديد
ليحل مكان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وخاصه
ان هناك وجوه محبوبه جدا ولديها شعبيه
كبيره في الجهه الاخرى من المعارضه مثلا
مثل اكرم امام اوغلو وايضا
رئيس بلديه انقره
نعم منصور نعم صحيح
بالفعل الرئيس اردوغان قالها الدستوريه
القانونيا اراد ان يتنافس بعد خمس سنوات
يحق له ولكنه قال للمواطنين الاتراك
ادعموني للمره الاخيره وهذه اذا اخر
انتخابات يقودها الرئيس اردوغان اخر خمس
سنوات له على الساحه السياسيه التركيه
بشكل اساسي صحيح انه هناك وجوها
كثيره ولديها ربما شعبيه ولكن اللافت
استاذه ميسون هو ليس ان هذه النسبه التي
حصل عليها كما كريشتار حصل عليها
لانه هو كمالك وليس لانه يتبع لحزب الشعب
الجمهوري هذه نقطه في غايه الاهميه حصل
على هذه النسب الكبيره وهذا التنافس على
الشديد الذي كان على اوجه وكانت الانفاس
محبوسه ايام حبس في الصدور بسبب هذا
التنوع في التكتل السداسي السؤال الاهم
الان هل سوف يبقى هذا التكتل او هذه
الطاوله السداسيه على ما هي عليه ام سوف
نرى تتفكك شيئا فشيئا هذا بسبب عدم مهند
دكتور مهند المعارضه واذا كانت ستبقى
ستتفكك هذا امر اخر ولكن على العداله
والتنميه هل هناك
نيه من
من ابراز وجوه جديده حتى يكمل هذا الحزب
لانه هذا الحزب مرتبط منذ 20 عاما بشخصيه
رجب طيب اردوغان
صحيح ولكن اظن ان هناك كوادر فاعله وقويه
في حزب العداله والتنميه وان كانت السنوات
الخمس القادمه سوف يكون هناك الكثير من
العمل في داخل حزب العداله والتنميه بشكل
اساسي
ليكون هناك من هو مهيا ليخوض الانتخابات
القادمه في عام 2022
هناك جهد كبير
ايضا مثل الانتخابات الرئاسيه بالنسبه
لحزب العداله والتنميه هل سيكون هناك
تغيير ما في السياسه خاصه بعد هذه
الانتقادات لحكم رجب طيب اردوغان في
الاونه الاخيره حتى يستطيع ان يربح في 20
24 بالانتخابات البلديه هو وحزبه وتحالفه
40 ثانيه لدينا
استنادا الى ما حققه رئيس اردوغان من
نتائج واستنادا الى التدهور الخدمات في
اسطنبول بشكل اساسي وفي انقره اظن وحسب
تصريح الرئيس اردوغان قبل قليل في اسطنبول
بانه سوف يستعيد اسطنبول بشكل اساسي
لحزب العداله والتنميه فانني اظن ان العمل
سوف يكون على قدم وساق لحزب العداله
والتنميه لكي يستعيد اسطنبول من حزب الشعب
الجمهوري شكرا لك من اسطنبول لدكتور مهند
حافظ اوغلو الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي كما
اشكر من اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
هشام جوناي واشكر ايضا ضيفنا الذي فقدنا
الاتصال به دكتور سمير صالحه خلال هذه
الساعه الاخباريه العربيه ما زالت مستمره
في هذه التغطيه لنتائج انتخابات التركيه
وانتخاب الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان رئيسا
لتركيا لخمس سنوات قادمه وانما الان نتابع
مع الزميل صهيب شراير اليك صهيب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات